welcome to this video playing waves from
Dominican Republic okay some Queens
gambit yeah the triangle always like
this line for white I think black can
equalize SEO again with most own
somewhat mainland openings but it's not
so easy chat like players often have a
hard time it's a strange move maybe this
i'm not quite sure
it's strange because well black doesn't
want to take 1 T 2 and we'll have to
retreat in the in the near future so
maybe this and then we should be three
grabbing that grabbing that tempo 187 k
if I castle night f4 maybe we're ki can
check on you 27 @ then move the night we
should a 6 i'm going nite c4 ok not
doing that so that's not bad on info add
a couple of ways to play this i can
switch to someone King side operation
with Queenie 222 night somewhere Queenie
for I can try to play for prevention of
c-5 I think I'm going for them for the
kingside operation for Queenie for next
so Queen you form now I guess Queen g4
and then i th five inches it's going to
be very very dangerous
meet on g7
Jim
question is is that winning right away
or can I can is somehow can you somehow
avoid a direct loss may I can take one
g6 even home okay Bishop g6 maybe maybe
maybe I'm Butchie aid but I can check
and then take one g6 let's go into work
yeah that's impossible to survive
all kinds of Bishop moose are check made
yeah best chance is neither for hoping
that I pre-move bishop at six or
something like that yeah tried that
that is in fact continuing for a moment
okay I can take six as well but let's
just take this check queen is good
enough black resigns yeah that's this is
some this line does not really am allow
that many inaccurate moves check and
this is should before it's already
somewhat somewhat shaky I think yeah yes
just has to improve so somewhere around
here this sister looks kind of okay but
yeah maybe see five or so I don't know
c5 is what he did went here and now okay
now he has to prevent Queenie for with
97 I didn't really see that move in the
game but that's a good one it's kind of
a little bit counterintuitive to remove
the night from the five which is well
looking good but you have to prevent
Queenie for I think after that it's
almost it's almost lost f5 was Stefan
after which this is already very
dangerous this is probably only move
it's given by the computer put the Bob +
+ have a pawn yeah but that's really not
what you want with black however it's
better than this is just flat can
flat-out users now it was a quick peace
peace based attack okay thanks for
watching